rien ici rien là non plus c'est quand
même incroyable je ne comprends plus
rien ou at il pu passer enfin rien enfin
il n'y a quand même pas de voleurs dans
l'île aux enfants c'est pas possible
bonjour vous n'auriez pas vu mon sucre
d'orge à la pomme non ça c'est un
magnifique et très grand sucre d'orge
que je lis il m'avait offert par ce que
je lui ai gardé son kiosque
eh bien il a disparu mais heureusement
j'ai lancé un appel à la radio de l'île
est le plus grand détective du monde va
arriver d'un instant à l'autre il va
m'aider à leur prouver il n'a pas pu
disparaître il faut que l'on retrouve
sur ce chrono
[Musique]
je mets ce que monsieur merluche merlot
au merlan fumée je suis très content de
vous voir excuses et menace était animée
par la fumée
no look fun ce moment l'accord si vous
voulez si vous voulez et bien expliqué
j'étais gêné ce qui se fait à cesser
voilà j m'a offert un magnifique est
délicieuse sucre d'orge à la pomme vous
avez besoin est mais c'est kevin et le
sucre pun s'émeut février
j'en accepte très bien une petite moss
mari mais malheureusement il a disparu
c'est justement pour ça quand ça vous ai
fait venir monsieur amerloques forme
aussi ne craignez rien monsieur finir je
vais commencer tout de suite
magnette c'est vrai tu écris un
formidable
vous êtes une efficacité n'est ce pas
alors vous mettez d ici un petit instant
et je vais me concentrer afin de
rechercher les indices premier ira bien
très bien
[Musique]
ce quasi mais je salue et vous qu'est-ce
que ça et mais qui êtes-vous il me
semble vous avoir déjà vu quelque part
impossible chers amis je suis fait mal
mais le plus grand détective du monde
ah bon mais c'est curieux monsieur
mauvaise excuse mais mon nom est molle
moment d'accord - metz mais il ya
quelque chose d'étrange c'est qu'il y à
déjà ici par un autre plus grand
détective du monde grasset bon c'est une
terrible il pense que oui et bien c'est
peut-être une une
comme vous dites là mais n'empêche qui
est là ce détective a l'air de bien
connaître son métier
tant pis je commence de ce côté nous
verrons bien qui est le meilleur vous
n'avez même pas demander ce qu'il
fallait chercher nano c'est vrai mais je
sais que vous allez me dire vous êtes
formidables il s'agit d'un énorme et
délicieux sucre d'orge à la pomme
devrait bien signer c'est bon mais
pourquoi est ce qu'ils font que je suis
et bien c'est pour bien montrer que vous
m'avez engagé évidemment on écoute la
fin d'une seconde je vais demander un
crayon comme comme vous voudrez
alors monsieur maurice est ce que vous
avez trouvé quelque chose plutôt que
mais j'aimerais que vous me disiez quel
est le personnage qui est habillé comme
nous à l'aide
comment mais vous ne le connaissez pas
mais c'est un autre plus grand détective
du monde
oui monsieur maurice vous vous n'avez
jamais rencontré au congrès des
détectives mais bon je n'en doute pas
mais j'aimerais quand même bien
retrouver mon sucre d'orge et bien ne
craignez rien crédit mais ça fait 2 ms
très bien je vous fais confiance moi je
vais avoir l'air d'un imbécile si ce
monsieur mal mais c'est véritablement le
plus grand détective du nord ce
détective de mahler est vraiment plus
grand du monde je suis perdu que se
passe tu prends le ballon tu ne dis rien
que l'on verra tout à l'heure un
détective mars handball on croit plutôt
qu'il s'agit d'un marchand de ballons
qui joue les détectives à moi de jouer
non pas avant comme vous ayez à prouver
mon sucre d'orge par questions psycho
rigide et des kits le faire signer une
feuille qui ressemble tout à fait un
contrat je vais surveiller sa discrétion
je vais loigné ce gêneur de marchand de
ballons
il ne manque vraiment pas l'air
extraordinaires ces deux détectives
il faut pourtant que je retrouve mon
sucre d'orge moi monsieur monsieur alors
vous prétendez avec le plus vindicatif
d'humains mais vous demain maintenant
vous jetterez en voulant fait signer une
feuille contrat casimir mèche et rêvent
les et vous vous avez commis la bêtise
de vendre un ballon françois sais que je
vais vous dénonciez à casimir eh bien je
vais moi aussi vous dénoncez non ne
faites surtout pas vous en prie vous non
plus on est alors à une condition c'est
que vous quittiez le jardin immédiate
n'a je veux bien mais vous partez aussi
pas d'accord il est temps que je
redevienne françois tant pis pour ceux
d'histoire du coup de sucre d'orge
craquerez vous je suis de votre avis il
vaut mieux éviter nouvelle colère de
casimir après vos sacs
c'est vraiment dommage alors un sucre
d'orge tient vers un si bon goût mais je
m'en souviens si je me souviens du goût
du sucre d'orge sais que je vais manger
mais oui je les mange et oulalalala
monsieur maurice et paul masseron être
absolument furieux il faut que j'aille
me cachais discrètement